[Music]
throughout history
different cultures all over the world
reference a great tournament
that dragon marking i think it's an
invitation
to fight for something known
as mortal kombat i've always talked
about respecting the material
and respecting the fans they all deserve
to see their beloved characters elevated
to this cinematic height
this really comes across as a powerful
experience that we haven't seen before
it's this grounded dramatic but silent
tale
what is so striking about motor combat
is how expensive
the story is it's epic
we have all the great characters that
the fans love
i'm sonya name's jax that's kano
i'm luke
lord ryden
[Music]
the interesting thing about playing a
video game character is that you have to
walk this line
of being larger than life but also
making that person real
there's actually rich emotional life
behind every single character
we need to be authentic you need actors
who can perform the actual movements
and stunts it's mind-blowing what they
do
and i think that fight element that has
always been in the game
can be brought to life on the screen and
it's not for cj i promise you
no matter how many of my people you put
in the ground
we will not fail
i've always believed that something
elegant and beautiful
can cohabitate with brutal and primal
all of the detail gives the audience a
sense of realism and connectivity to
this world
the first time that i started seeing all
these guys in costume i was blown away
they've completely brought all of these
characters to life
this is more than just seeing a movie
produced this is
seeing something that i've been
passionate about my whole life finally
come to the screen
i love working on this kind of
international project
[Music]
it really represents the mortal kombat
world
i hope it's both a reward for the fans
and
a new experience
don't be fooled that it's just a game
it's more than that
it's cinematic it's beautiful there's
heart and there's emotion
all those ingredients together it should
be a fun powerful ride
so enjoy get over here
[Music]
[Music]
first learned about this seven years ago
on a mission in brazil
to capture a wanted fugitive
when we got there it tore through our
unit in seconds
the target has superhuman abilities
[Applause]
[Music]
it had the same marking you do cole
it's a birthmark what do you mean he was
born with it
it's not a birthmark cole means you've
been chosen
throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament
world champions that dragon marking
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
as mortal kombat
these are your champions i'm sonya
that's kano i'm luke
[Applause]
no matter how many of my people you put
in the ground
we will not fail kill them
i am zero
get over here
you [ __ ] beauty
[Music]
you